ja das gute leute was genau zwicker beim
ein video auf jeden fall
wie ihr schon sehen ich kann mich hier
so super cool im kreis rennen ich habe
mir die mich jetzt überhaupt verstand
ich habe auf jeden fall ist die hog
gekauft es ist mitternacht beim make a
book damit zu fahren
na ja jetzt alles schön neidisch auf
jeden fall habe ich mir gedacht komm ich
habe euch gäste doch instagram gefragt
ja stellt mir doch mal so aufgaben die
ich damit erledigen soll das hat man
schon ein paar andere youtuber gemacht
und ich habe einfach drauf deswegen gibt
es heute auch noch von mir sind wirklich
lustige sachen dabei hoffe ich und ich
verkaufe ich alles hinkriege und wie oft
ich mich da aufs maul legen werde werden
wir sehen ich wünsche euch viel spaß
wenn es euch überlassen da nach oben
haben wird man dann von kamera und
zweiten teil machen
deswegen warten erst mal ab bis nach dem
video ich sag mal so sobald wir 10.000
likes auf diesem video haben kommt
direkt der zweite teil davon zehn sagen
wir 8000 8000 keine ahnung ich will auch
eigentlich gar nicht lange lagern und
direkt am anfang und zwar mit der ersten
aufgabe okay wir fangen erst mal
vielleicht noch einfach anfahren mit
einem fuß und einer hand diese aufgabe
stellt kati 0 und das probieren wir doch
gleich mal aus okay leute also ich weiß
mit einem fuß und einer hand so ich
glaube ich erst mal mit beiden füßen
drauf
alles klar
jetzt mal nach vorne und mir zurück aber
auch gar nicht mal so schlecht von
anfang glaubt jetzt mit 2 jahren kann
man machen habe ich noch was mein
safestick kaputtgemacht gibt's ja gar
nicht so laut ich würde sagen die
nächste aufgabe schon etwas
komplizierter und zwar fragte christina
oder so ein glas wasser auf dem kopf
balancieren und ich so oft wie möglich
dabei drehen aber aus okay leute hier
ist jetzt wasser nicht dass jetzt
anstellen soll weiß ich auch noch nicht
so ganz
also auch mein kopf stellen seht ihr das
über ja ja
ein glas weniger fakten nicht dumme habe
ich denn glas genommen hätten becher
nehmen können oder ja vielleicht hätte
ich diese aufgabe auch zum schluss
drehen soll jetzt etwas du also sorry
aber das hab ich jetzt nicht hinbekommen
ich habe ja viel bekommen ist jetzt
schon aber das nicht jetzt schneide ich
mich schon sicher wer diese aufgabe
gestellt so ihr geht jetzt ab das profil
von der und hätte die tod ein spaß leute
macht ihr nichts wie er mal wieder hält
mich hingelegt und verletzte ich mich
nachher noch so leute nächste aufgabe
von alex singer sie sagt ich soll doch
mal ohne hände und füße fahren
probieren wir auf direkte haus jetzt
glauben so jetzt will ich nicht meine
hände und füße benutzen wir schlagen
erst mal wieder ab hände und füße knie
dürftig theoretisch mit
aber ich versuche mit dem bauch er kennt
gar nicht dass ich darauf liege
vielleicht wartet machen seht ihr mich
überhaupt
ich mache jetzt mal 100 meter darauf
erkennbar wird ja doch das ist aber
möglich also ich habe jetzt nur meine
hände drauf damit ich vorankommen weil
wir sind so sensoren seht ihr
und wenn ich einfach drauf hier geht es
nicht kann es natürlich mal mit den
knien machen hilfe nicht kaputtgehen gut
mal ganz locker lässig aber mit dem
clean ist das ja einfach war
hoppala ist gut hatte ich auch lief so
jetzt deswegen versucht das jetzt mal
als ich nicht nur meine hände auf und
legt nicht an draufklicken jetzt erstmal
hier drauf jetzt liege ich und jetzt
ja das gute hilfe ok europa na ja gar
nicht mal so schlecht so diaby 20 stellt
mir die aufgabe zehn bis 15 mal im kreis
drehen und dann eine flasche oder
ähnliches das weiter weg steht auf
sammeln können wir auch noch versuchen
schlimmer denn je was ihn also ich
stelle hier und jetzt die flasche hin
und gehen auch nach vielen drehe mich
die ganze zeit und dann versuche ich die
flasche zu kriegen okay let's go so
leute ich hab hier jetzt ein glas das
stelle ich jetzt genau hierhin hier
unten steht das jetzt und ich dreh mich
jetzt sagen wir 15 leute ich mich jetzt
okay dann versuche ich das glas zu
ergattern
das kann ich gut in 10 fasten ist die
letzte 15 und glas
naja ihr alter ich hätte jetzt erstes
gehabt dass ich mich voll gegen diese
kante legen
wenn die da drauf steht dreht etwa 15
mal unter anderem auch auf seinen dingen
ich hab's nicht so ganz geschafft aber
egal so weit und die letzte aufgabe von
lx fauna oder so sie eine hose an werden
oft im leben steht
das wird glaube ich richtig schwer ich
weiß es nicht weil man muss ja dann ich
habe mir hier diese jogginghose
rausgesucht wir probieren das einfach
mal aus ich kann jetzt schlecht meine
hose ausziehen oder soll ich mein großes
ziel
jetzt solltet ihr diese hose und die
wird jetzt versuchen anzuziehen wenn ich
mich jetzt wenn ich wenn ich das nicht
schaffe und hier mitten in der hose
stecken dann mache ich mich so heftig
das ist mir schon etwas riskant aber wir
versuchen es macht erst links aber erst
recht okay okay
alter schützt so locker weg ganz einfach
mir war klar dass ich hoffe aber ich
wollte die spannung aufbauen also ja
dann würde ich sagen das war es erstmal
mit diesem video ich habe ihm gesagt
wenn es euch gefallen hat also zweiter
teil kann man da von mega riesige
stellen wir auch weitere aufgaben hier
unten in den kommentaren auf jeden fall
was ich so in der zweiten folge machen
soll
wie kommt dann wirklich bei 10.000 6 das
ist machbar er hat sich vielleicht viel
an aber wir schaffen das locker und dann
würde ich sagen aber nicht vergessen in
socken und so da könnt ihr mir auch die
aufgabe stellt war eingewendet blabla
und hier oben links geht's weiter mit
meinem letzten video das war irgendwie
so bei jedem jungen die dritte ausgabe
unseres lebens nächsten mittwoch wieder
auf rädern
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen
sonntag